THE SENATE
COMMITTEE. COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WILL NOW COME TO
ORDER. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
HEARING TODAY IN ROOM 2200 OF
THE SWING SPACE. I ASK THAT ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE COME TO
THE HEARING ROOM. SO THAT
BECAUSE WE ARE GOING TO
ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM RIGHT THIS
MINUTE, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CABALLERO. HERE. CABALLERO.
HERE. JONES I'M HERE. JONES.
HERE. ASHBY. BECKER HERE.
BECKER. HERE. BRADFORD. CIERTO.
HERE. CIERTO HERE. WAHAB. WE
HAVE A QUORUM. WE HAVE 32
MEASURES ON TODAY'S AGENDA, ALL
OF WHICH ARE SUSPENSE
CANDIDATES. ALL MEMBERS WITH
BILLS BEFORE THE COMMITTEE HAVE
WAIVED PRESENTATION. BUT WE WILL
TAKE TESTIMONY FROM THE PUBLIC
ON EACH ITEM. I ALSO WANT TO
ANNOUNCE THAT SB 1308 BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ IS STILL LISTED IN THE
DAILY FILE, BUT THAT MEASURE
WILL BE RESCHEDULED FOR OUR NEXT
HEARING NEXT WEEK. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS
INDICATED THAT THEY DO NOT HAVE
A FILE ON ANY OF THE MEASURES
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE, AND THE
REPRESENTATIVES WILL NOT BE
PRESENT TO TESTIFY, SO THAT
SHOULD MAKE THE TESTIMONY GO
FAIRLY QUICKLY. SO I WANT TO
BEGIN BY REMINDING ANY WITNESSES
OR WITNESSES THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY, TO LIMIT THEIR
TESTIMONY TO THE FISCAL ASPECTS
OF THE BILL. AND PLEASE REFRAIN
FROM LENGTHY POLICY DISCUSSIONS
AND REPEATING PRIOR TESTIMONY IN
YOUR COMMENTS. SO WE'VE
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM, SO WE'RE
GOING TO JUMP RIGHT IN TO THE
FIRST ITEM ON OUR CALENDAR,
WHICH IS SB 909 BY SENATOR
UMBERG. THE STEPHEN M THOMPSON
PHYSICIAN CORPS LOAN REPAYMENT
PROGRAM, AS I SAID BEFORE, THIS
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE,
AND SENATOR UMBERG HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. SO WE'LL GO
DIRECTLY TO THE WITNESS
TESTIMONY. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM 2200 WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB 909? IF SO, PLEASE COME
FORWARD. IS THERE ANY INDIVIDUAL
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF SB 909 HERE IN ROOM 2200?
WELL, I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
WITNESSES THAT CAME FORWARD, AS
I SAID, THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE FILES ON
ON THIS BILL. AND SO WE'LL,
UNLESS THERE IS A RAVING NEED
FOR A QUESTION OR COMMENT, THE
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 909 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO THIS
SECOND ITEM, WHICH IS SB 955 BY
SENATOR SATO. OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH INFRASTRUCTURE GAP
FUND PROGRAM. IS THERE ANY
MEMBER, AGAIN, SENATOR SATO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION, SO WE'LL GO
DIRECTLY TO THE WITNESS
TESTIMONY. ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
IN ROOM 2200 WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 955?
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO SB 955?
AGAIN THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DOES NOT HAVE ANY FILES ON THIS
BILL, SO WE WILL BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MEMBERS. I
HAVE SOME SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT
THEIR THEIR THEIR THERE HAS BEEN
A SERIOUS CONCERNED WAVE. BUT
REGARDLESS THIS IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB 955 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. THE NEXT BILL IS SB
978 BY SENATOR SATO. STATE
GOVERNMENT BUDGET. STATE
PUBLICATIONS AND FORMAT, THE
SENATOR HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION,
SO WE'LL GO GO DIRECTLY TO
WITNESS TESTIMONY. ANYBODY WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB 978. SEEING NONE, ANYBODY
WHO WOULD WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB 978.
I CONSIDER IT. ALL RIGHT, THAT'S
IT. GLOVES ARE OFF. SEEING NO
ONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION, THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE. SO, THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 978 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
SB 957 BY SENATOR WIENER. DATA
COLLECTION, SEXUAL ORIENTATION
AND GENDER IDENTITY. THE SENATOR
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION, SO
WE'LL GO DIRECTLY TO WITNESS
TESTIMONY. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES THAT WOULD LIKE, HERE
IN ROOM 2200 WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 957?
WELCOME. GOOD MORNING, NICOLE
MORALES, ON BEHALF OF CHILDREN
NOW IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? IS THERE ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB 957? IF YOU'RE
DOING THIS AND I FIGURED OUT BY
ME SEEING NO ONE, THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE
ON THIS BILL. SO, WE'LL BRING IT
BACK TO MEMBERS SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR QUESTIONS. THE
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 957 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB
959 BY SENATOR MENGIBAR TRANS
INCLUSIVE CARE RESOURCES AND
SUPPORT SERVICES, THE SENATOR
MENGIBAR HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION, SO WE'LL GO
DIRECTLY TO WITNESS TESTIMONY.
IS THERE ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB 959,
NICOLE MORALES, ON BEHALF OF
CHILDREN NOW IN SUPPORT, THANK
YOU SO MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? IS THERE ANYBODY WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB 959, SEEING
NONE AGAIN, THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON
THIS BILL. SO WE'LL BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
. SEEING NONE, THE BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 959 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 1281 BY SENATOR
MENGIBAR ADVANCING EQUITY AND
ACCESS IN THE SELF-DETERMINATION
PROGRAM. THE SENATOR MENGIBAR
AGAIN HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION,
SO WE'LL GO DIRECTLY TO WITNESS
TESTIMONY. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM 2200 WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL? ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
THÀNH SEEING NONE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE ON THIS MATTER. SO
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE. FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1281 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 965 BY
SENATOR MINH. SENATOR MINH HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION, SO WE'LL GO
DIRECTLY TO WITNESS TESTIMONY.
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? IS
THERE ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION? SEEING
NONE AGAIN, THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON
THIS MATTER. SO THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 965 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 967 BY
SENATOR PADILLA, UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA PILOT PROJECT DUST
FORECAST AND WARNING SYSTEM,
IMPERIAL COUNTY AND COACHELLA
VALLEY. SENATOR PADILLA HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION IN. ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM 2200
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? IS THERE ANYBODY IN
ROOM 2200 THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB 967?
SEEING NONE, THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON
THIS BILL. SO THE BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 967 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 995 BY
SENATOR PADILLA, CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY HIGH QUALITY
TEACHER RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION RETENTION ACT. SENATOR
PADILLA HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON
THIS BILL. SO, WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 995 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO SB 991 BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ SCHOOL
DISTRICTS LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT INSPECTOR
GENERAL. SENATOR GONZALEZ HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB 991? WELCOME. GOOD
MORNING, ANA IOAKIMIDIS ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT, PROUD
CO-SPONSOR. IN ADDITION TO THE
OFFICE OF THE INSPECTOR GENERAL,
ALLOWING LOS ANGELES UNIFIED TO
DETECT FRAUD AND DETER WASTE
WITH PROPOSITION WITH PROP 98
FUNDS, THIS BILL ALSO IS FULLY
DISTRICT FUNDED AND DOES NOT
HAVE A COST TO THE STATE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? IS THERE ANYONE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 991? SEEING
NONE, THIS BILL IS SUSPENDED
AGAIN. THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON ON THIS
BILL. AND SO THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 991 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO SB 1131
BY SENATOR GONZALEZ. MEDI-CAL
PROVIDERS. SENATOR GONZALEZ HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. SO WE'LL
MOVE ON TO TESTIMONY. IS THERE
ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL?
IS THERE ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
1131? SEEING NO NO FURTHER
TESTIMONY, THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON
THIS BILL, AND IT IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1131 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. OH, I'M SORRY. YES I
HAVE THAT RIGHT. RIGHT OKAY.
MOVING ON TO 1182, BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ, MASTER PLAN FOR
HEALTHY, SUSTAINABLE AND CLIMATE
RESILIENT SCHOOLS. SENATOR
GONZALEZ HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION
THÀNH. IS THERE ANYBODY WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL? HELLO, CHAIR
MEMBERS SAM NASH WITH THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, NICOLE
MORALES, ON BEHALF OF CHILDREN
NOW IN SUPPORT, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ANYBODY
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NO ONE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE ON THIS, AND IT IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1182 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO SB 1003
BY SENATOR DODD ELECTRICAL
CORPORATIONS WILDFIRE MITIGATION
PLAN. SENATOR DODD HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ANY
WITNESSES WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION? THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS NO
FILE ON THIS, AND IT IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1003 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
SB 1384 BY SENATOR DODD. IT
POWERED WHEELCHAIRS REPAIR.
SENATOR DODD HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. GREGORY KRAMER, ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NONE, THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON THIS
BILL. SO THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1384 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO SB 1007
BY SENATOR BRADFIELD BRADFORD
HOUSING HOMEOWNER ASSISTANCE AND
HOMEOWNERS ASSISTANCE FOR
DESCENDANTS OF ENSLAVED PERSONS
PROGRAM. IS THERE ANYBODY IN THE
SENATE? SENATOR BRADFORD HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
. WELCOME YES. GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS KIM MIMS WITH THE
COALITION FOR A JUST AND
EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA FOR,
AMERICAN REDRESS COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA, ARC, SACRAMENTO AND
AMEND THE MASS MEDIA GROUP HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB 1007.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YES. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
DARLENE CROMARTIE. I AM A MEMBER
OF THE COALITION FOR A JUST AND
EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA, AS WELL AS
THE AMERICAN REDRESS COALITION
OF CALIFORNIA, ARC BAY AREA AND
I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
1007. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS GREGORY
KRAMER ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA, IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? SEEING NO ONE ELSE, IS
THERE ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB 1007? SEEING NONE AGAIN. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS NO
FILE ON THIS BILL. THE BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1007 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
SB 1017 BY SENATOR EGGMAN.
AVAILABLE FACILITIES FOR
INPATIENT AND RESIDENTIAL MENTAL
HEALTH OR SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT. SENATOR EGGMAN HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION, SO WE'LL
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES. ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
. IS THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION? THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL. SO.
AND IT IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1017 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO SB 1025 BY SENATOR
EGGMAN. PRETRIAL DIVERSION FOR
VETERANS. SENATOR EGGMAN HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION ON HER BILL.
IS THERE ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? IS THERE
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE, THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL, AND IT
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1025 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO
SB 1095 BY SENATOR BECKER. COZY
HOMES CLEANUP ACT BUILDING
STANDARDS, GAS, FUEL BURNING
APPLIANCES. I LIKE THAT TITLE
COZY HOMES. WHO'S GOING TO VOTE
AGAINST COZY HOMES? I'M SORRY, I
DIGRESS. THE SENATOR HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION, SO WE'RE GOING TO
SEE IF THERE IS ANYBODY WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY HERE IN
SUPPORT. IS THERE ANYBODY WHO IS
WHO IS HERE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE, THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS NO
FILE ON THIS BILL, AND IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1095 WILL MOVE TO
THE SUSPENSE FILE. MOVING ON TO
SB 1113 BY SENATOR NEWMAN.
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
PILOT PROJECTS EXTENSION. SEN.
NEWMAN HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION
ON HIS BILL. SO IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? ANYONE HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE, THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE. AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE. CAÑADA SO SB 1113
WILL MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE FILE
SB 1119 BY SENATOR NEWMAN
HOSPITALS SEISMIC COMPLIANCE AND
URGENCY. SEN. NEWMAN HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT? GOOD
MORNING, GRACE KOPLAN ON BEHALF
OF PROVIDENCE. PROUD TO SPONSOR
SB 1119. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN SUPPORT?
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION? THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE. AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO SB
1119 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB
12 1244 BY SENATOR NEWMAN.
SENATOR NEWMAN HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. SO WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO SUPPORT ANYONE HERE
IN SUPPORT. NICOLE MERRILEES ON
BEHALF OF CHILDREN NOW IN
SUPPORT. VERY GOOD. GOOD
MORNING. VALERIE JOHNSON WITH
THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? SEEING NO NO FURTHER
TESTIMONY, THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE IN
THIS MATTER. SO AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO SB
1244 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE SB
1187 BY SENATOR MCGUIRE. HOUSING
PROGRAMS. TRIBAL HOUSING
RECONSTITUTION AND RESILIENCY
ACT. SENATOR MCGUIRE HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYBODY
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT?
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS GREGORY
KRAMER ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT? ANYONE IN OPPOSITION?
SEEING NONE, THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON
THIS MATTER. AND THE BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1187 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE SB
1197 BY SENATOR ALVARADO GIL IN
HOME RESPITE SERVICES. SENATOR
ALVARADO GIL HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION SO IS THERE ANYONE
HERE IN SUPPORT? MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER, ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA, WE'RE A PROUD
CO-SPONSOR OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, NICOLE
MERRILEES, ON BEHALF OF CHILDREN
OUT IN SUPPORT, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT?
SEEING NONE. IS THERE ANYBODY
HERE IN OPPOSITION TO SB 1197?
SEEING NO OPPOSITION AGAIN, THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE. AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1197 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO SB 1213 BY SENATOR
ATKINS. HEALTH CARE PROGRAMS.
CANCER SENATOR ATKINS HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT?
ANYBODY WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NEITHER THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE. AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO,
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1213 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1245 OCHOA
IN-HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES.
LICENSED HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS PROFESSIONAL
CERTIFICATION THÀNH. SENATOR
OCHOA HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
IS THERE ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS.
CATHY'S UNDERLING MCDONALD, ON
BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT? ANYONE HERE IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING. NO
OPPOSITION. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE. SO
SB AND THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO SB 1245. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, WE'LL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE SB 1411 BY SENATOR
OCHOA BOGH INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY
COMMISSION MEMBERSHIP
APPOINTMENTS BY THE
INTERSEGMENTAL COMMITTEE OF THE
ACADEMIC SENATE. SENATOR OCHOA
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYBODY HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ANY
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION? SEEING
NONE. THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DOES NOT HAVE A FILE. AND THE
BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1411 THÀNH WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. SB 1248 SENATOR
HURTADO PUPIL HEALTH. EXTREME
WEATHER CONDITIONS, PHYSICAL
ACTIVITY. SENATOR HURTADO HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION THÀNH IS
THERE ANYBODY HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
1248? ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB 1248? AGAIN, THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE.
AND THE BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1248 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE SB
1258 BY SENATOR DALLI. MEDI-CAL
UNRECOVERED PAYMENTS. INTEREST
RATES. SENATOR DALLI HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYBODY
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? IS
THERE ANYBODY PRESENT TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION? SEEING NEITHER
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES
NOT HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL AND
IT IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE.
SO SB 1258, WITHOUT OBJECTION,
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. SB 1318
SENATOR WAHAB PUPIL HEALTH
SUICIDE PREVENTION POLICIES AND
PUPIL SUICIDE CRISIS. SENATOR
WAHAB HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION
THÀNH. THANK YOU FOR DOING THAT.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT?
ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NEITHER THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE FILES. AND
THIS IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
SB 1318 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON TO SB 1322 BY SENATOR
WAHAB FOSTER, YOUTH CHAFEE
EDUCATIONAL AND TRAINING
VOUCHERS PROGRAM. SENATOR WAHAB
AGAIN HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION
ANY ONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. MEMBER KATHY
SONDERLING MCDONALD AGAIN FOR
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. VERY PLEASED TO
SPONSOR THE LEGISLATION. THIS
BILL WOULD MOVE CALIFORNIA AGE
FROM 16, WHERE IT IS TODAY, DOWN
TO 14 OR 15 FOR YOUTH WHO LEFT
FOSTER CARE TO BE ABLE TO APPLY
FOR CHAFEE EDUCATION AND
TRAINING VOUCHERS, THOSE HELP
THEM FILL GAPS IN OTHER SUPPORT
THAT THEY RECEIVE TO ATTEND
COLLEGE OR POST-SECONDARY
EDUCATION. JUST A COUPLE OF
FISCAL NOTES. WHILE THE BILL IS
ON SUSPENSE, WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH YOUR STAFF AND OF
COURSE, THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE, AS
WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT
AID COMMISSION, TO THINK ABOUT
HOW HOW THE FUNDS COULD BE
CONTINUE TO BE PRIORITIZED FOR
THE YOUTH WHO ARE ELIGIBLE TODAY
SO AS NOT TO DISPLACE THOSE
YOUTH BECAUSE THE PROGRAM IS
OVERSUBSCRIBED. BUT WE DO THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO GET TO THAT
SAME AGE AS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ALLOWS. AND THEN SEE
THE DEMAND FOR THE PROGRAM SO
THAT WHEN TIMES ARE BETTER, WE
CAN MAKE THAT ARGUMENT TO BOTH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AS WELL
AS HERE IN THE STATE, TO RECEIVE
MORE FUNDS FOR THIS IMPORTANT
PROGRAM. YOUTH REALLY DESERVE
THE SUPPORT, AND WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT AS YOU CONSIDER SUSPENSE
LATER IN THE SESSION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SAM NASH,
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
NICOLE MERRILEES, ON BEHALF OF
CHILDREN NOW IN SUPPORT. THANKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? IS THERE
ANY ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
1322? SEEING NONE AGAIN, THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE ON THIS. AND THIS IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO SB
1322. WITHOUT OBJECTION, WE'LL
MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE FILE. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO SB 1404 BY
SENATOR GLAZER. POLITICAL REFORM
ACT OF 1974 AUDITS. SENATOR
GLAZER HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL? ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE
TO ATTEST TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NEITHER THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS NO FILE AND THE BILL
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1404 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AND LAST BUT
NOT LEAST, SB 1463 BY SENATOR
NILO. DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES
SELF-DETERMINATION PROGRAM
DEPUTY DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
SELF-DETERMINATION SENATOR NILO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION, SO
WE'LL MOVE ON TO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF 1480 1463. ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NEITHER THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE AND THE BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, SB 1463 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. ALL RIGHTY.
THAT CONCLUDES OUR BILLS FOR
TODAY. I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY
FOR GETTING HERE RIGHT ON TIME,
WE ARE GOING TO HOLD THE ROLL
OPEN FOR A FEW MINUTES, LET'S
SEE IF WE CAN, CATCH UP WITH,
SENATORS THAT ARE BUSY IN OTHER
COMMITTEES ARE LATE GETTING
LATE, OR I WON'T, I WON'T, I
WON'T SAY LATE, LATE GETTING
HERE, BUT THAT MAY BE MAY BE THE
CASE. WAIT TILL HE'S OUT. OKAY
SO. PICKED UP. OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. YEAH. WE'RE DONE, I
THINK SHE'S COMING. ALL RIGHT.
FOR YOU, I'M GOING TO START
USING, YOU KNOW. YEAH. NO, IT'S
COZY HOME. SHE DOESN'T WANT IT.
WHO WANTS AN UNCLE? YOU KNOW,
IT'S ACTUALLY MY STAFFER WHO
CAME UP WITH THAT. I TOLD HER
THAT, YOU KNOW, IT'S LIKE, COME
ON, I WISH I HAD THOUGHT ABOUT
IT. YEAH.
WE'RE GOING TO CALL A BRIEF
RECESS OF THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
SO I'D
LIKE TO THANK EVERYBODY FOR
PARTICIPATING IN TODAY'S HEARING
. WE HAVE NOW CONCLUDED THE
AGENDA. SO THE MEETING OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS IS ADJOURNED.